bootleg cab podcast you already know man
go get the new album hit boy big hit
they're in the building whoa whoa let's
get right to it come on man
it's got to be like my third bootleg cam
free stuff
Surfer drone Vol 2 out right now hit boy
big hit
[Music]
a little [__] going
yes
my versus smoking tired smoking BF
Goodrich I popped the hood you got
popped in the hood showing you Hood Rich
flipping through this booklet we was
[__] up in a crowded van it sounded
bad when I heard the shouts of a
drowning man fake love I sniff it out
like a drug dog at the airport I move
pawns like pieces on the chessboard
beast mode with the harness in the leash
off and you gonna have a hard time
accepting this ass whooping thinking we
saw I tell a [__] I lost on some Drake
into one and don't be giving out that um
without saving me son and I hope you can
stay in the rain cause they stand on
that season I think it's mad the baddest
hoes be mad for no reason I'm disarming
the system I pull the plug snatch the
wires out my best friend had a brother
running from the fence hiding out I
still remember when he got knocked been
over 20 now it was pouring rain outside
I left my hoodie down I won't claim to
be a no at all but if I go I'mma go
crazy or I won't go at all I'm improving
myself done proving myself I seen them
dry their self insane strictly out of
fear losing the belt couldn't be me I
cut the samples up with shattered glass
Buck 50s and Banks gay won't be the same
aftermath like world war three they
stepping too long it's the wake-up call
Miami out to Vegas back to L.A spent the
80 bar when you black with confidence
they tell you you should be humble but
[__] a pat on the back I wanna see
[__] crumble they wanna snatch up all
my pieces for I complete the puzzle so
I'm going jigsaw without the bike in the
boats how I dump bodies in the lake take
my son for a boat ride enjoy the rest of
my day either get Slither you gonna
slide and it's about the time when it
start to make sense I might never return
to the person I was before this [__] hit
boy but I'm more than his My Life movie
lately the scariest horror flicks but I
find the beauty before I jump the Hoops
for any [__] I will drive a hoop to you
dumb if you don't know we crazy lit it's
a fact they afraid of this homie surface
round volume two out right now oh hey
boy
[Music]
how I'm gonna die Never Gonna Know could
be a heart attack could be a stroke pull
up in some [__] hood and get smoke drug
deal gone bad lick for my dough on bad
sleep some [__] slit my throat sleep at
the wheel off the cliff for my slicks
faux slip I'm making you my drink on
that low high speed the beers get caught
and get choked cover couldn't kill me
Jehovah just heal me literally I'm a
death bed thinking really how to shot
[__] how to rob [__] flock [__]
spot got right down the business
exchange bullets with option never been
popped sir rocks to the cops round and
never got caught survive race ride tuna
level four Prison surprise I'm alive
highly bucket did me shot down on the
gurney all them hunkies hurt me doc said
they murk me I bounce back like burpees
couple Wheels crap lungs had collapse
piss nurse learn words drugged up as
shackles wanna make it out alive don't
remember nothing then the doc said
hitting people's coming remember what I
said up and show your ass dead men in
L.A County Jail shares worse than the
fears
oh man
that's crazy big hit that's how we doing
it come on hey I know you just watched a
new freestyle guess what we're dropping
them every week sometimes more than once
a week Jesus we've been dropping a lot
lately uh shout out to LRG don't forget
go to
l-r-g.com use the promo code bootleg
save 30 off at checkout you get this
look at this jacket look at that lining
it's LRG baby 30 off this bad boy go to
l-r-g.com promo code bootleg and save 30
off at checkout and check out another
freestyle next week